I'm recanvass farm an orthopedic surgeon
in a two-man practice outside of Atlanta
Georgia we use the animations in the
practices and explored that possibility
because we found that we're telling
these patients the same thing all the
times the same repetition with respect
to meniscal injuries ACL injuries torn
Achilles and not only was a
time-consuming we discovered those
patients weren't remembering anything we
told them and they're always calling
back to get more information which is
not a particularly big deal we don't
mind giving it to them it just takes
time from the point of view of educating
patients and the from the point of view
of productivity the animations have been
a tremendous asset what it allows us to
do is to give the information to the
patients but then they can go home and
watch it themselves or they can sit in
the exam room and watch it several time
but while they're doing that I can go on
and see somebody else so not only does
it allow me to be more productive it's
cut back on the number of callbacks that
our staff is getting from patients that
have questions because the questions are
being answered in the comfort of their
own home when they're watching the
videos
the positive aspects to the practice the
positive benefits of this whole program
in some ways have been in measurable
because we don't have good metrics it's
a small practice but on the other hand
we can tell that we're increasing the
number of patients that we're seeing on
a daily basis and we're getting fewer
callbacks so the nursing staff is being
much more helpful with seeing patients
that are in the office rather than
spending time on the phone but by and
large the patients come in they have
fewer questions we don't have the
callbacks much better educated on
exactly what's going to be done
surgically and for the non surgical
patients they have a much better
understanding of why we're having to
protect them why they're wearing a brace
why they're doing the rehab so overall
it's been a much better patient
education and from a physicians point of
view I think we're getting better
results because the patient's truly
understand what's going on